dr. Yuji who is head of China for sites
at the London School of Economics well
doctor you let me start with you first
China Daily has today run an editorial
accusing the u.s. of bullying again do
you think Beijing's ready to compromise
I think we'll probably going to see a
major major concession made by Beijing
in the two days time of talk and the
most likely Beijing were further opening
up their financial sector as a show of a
willingness of back to negotiation table
reserved the trade dispute issues so
there's some discussion and the
concessions going on but really I think
these matter more than words in this
case I mean there's been an awful lot of
speculation as to whether China is
genuinely opening up its economy do you
believe that to be the case I believe I
mean this is a sign of weariness what a
shame ping wanted to I mean the
willingness there but that our problem
lies really down to implementation and
whether he's a team of economic team
willing to implement the economic plan
he set up so that's another matter
so I thinks a lot of compromise will
happen in behind or but really we need
to see the end result probably is too
soon to tell at this stage for the
moment well Rebecca let me bring you in
I mean it's been very striking that the
US has been downplaying expectations of
any deal being done is that in itself a
negotiating tactic I think you have to
see the u.s. approach to these
discussions is very much a negotiating
tactic so sending a large team which
means that they're actually trying to
create some noise there the Chinese have
already said they're not going to
negotiate with the gun against their
heads but equally as has already been
said there's a likelihood that the
Chinese will try and negotiate and come
to some kind of agreement but yes
there's a degree to which there's this
is all tactical by the US because
they've said themselves the decisions
ultimately are going to be made in
Washington the US delegation is
absolutely enormous isn't it and there
are lots of divisions between them and
you've got like Kaiser and Navarro who
are quite hawkish want to threaten the
Chinese with teres then on the other
hand you've got people like Larry cut
of course Steve minutiae in the Treasury
secretary who probably keen is to do a
deal I mean that does I help matters
I think it's an exercising can kicking
so what you've got there is essentially
you've got an ambassador and two
opposing groups so there's very little
likelihood that the two groups are going
to sing from the same song sheet so I
think what's likely to happen is there
will be a lot of discussions there will
be some negotiation in the end everybody
wants to avoid a trade war I don't think
it's the case that people really truly
want to have some kind of a direct
conflict in in trade terms between these
two countries so there will be a lot of
noise it will be very difficult for them
to come to a decision just because of
the size of the group usually you're
nodding an agreement there yes I very
much concur was the other dr. Harding
just said it's very much I mean the two
economies are so much intertwined in the
past few years so at the end of the day
if this a trade war a start
they'll be mutually destructive on both
sides so I don't think either Trump or
Xi Jinping would like to see this happen
one thing that we've learned over the
last few days though is that China has
kept at Lee canceled all of its soybean
imports from the United States which is
obviously a very very big element of
trade between the two countries i
mean--can china recently substitute
those supplies from elsewhere not easy
but china will probably looking for
alternatives I mean the Saudis would be
imported from countries like Brazil or
many other Latin American countries but
however China remain one of the major
importer for the US oil beans so I think
it's really for the moment it's a
temporary measure of what China's
government xx to try to sending a signal
to the US government there's a certain
quiet here at the can negotiate and
certain quite here at they cannot how do
you assess the effectiveness of the
tariffs that both sides have slapped at
each other so far so far I'd say they're
making very little difference if you
look at the proportion of trade that's
actually affected by all of this then
all it's doing is heightening the
rhetorical tensions between the two
countries and again to reiterate this is
rhetoric at
there's a there's some sort of border
skirmishes if you want to carry on with
the war analogy and what's likely to
happen is the discussions in Beijing are
going to focus on intellectual property
because that's the ultimate thing at
stake the the US wants to see their
trade deficit with China reduced by a
hundred billion dollars that's their
ultimate goal and to repatriate some of
the intellectual property or to make
sure that the intellectual property
developed in China is going to be is
going to be the US as well so that there
are bigger goals at stake and I think
these are just as a power power
brokering tactics at the moment very
interesting the US trade figures came
out this afternoon and the trade
deficits dropped by 15 percent month or
month and because a big rise at 15
percent rise in exports I think exports
a record time and is all this really
necessary from Donald Trump so I think
there's a very substantial sentiment out
there particularly once the economics
community saying why is he so obsessed
with the trade deficit because because
global trade is interdependent is my
definition global we have global supply
chains that originating the u.s. go to
China go to go across Asia come to
Europe and then go back to the US again
so obsessing about a trade deficit is
actually something that that is speaking
to his domestic audience and again this
is really important he's speaking to a
domestic audience this is America first
it's not about global trade I will
usually separately we've we just have
the index out which measures things like
freights volumes in China bank loan
origination electricity production and
it's it's shown a bit of a dip in recent
months should we be very concerned about
Chinese GDP growth not for the moment so
far say I mean if you look at the first
quarter number it looks rather positive
unstable I think part of the reason why
the fourth quarter began dip a little
bit I think the first reason is the
holiday so you have this long type of
holiday in February and of course that
trickle-down impact on the general
economic performance